I chose to be wonder where actually
because I stole the nickname from my
cousin my oldest oldest cousin will add
the name in the world of warcraft like
when it came up and he had it because it
was underwear with a W in front and it's
just sounded cool
first time I played League of Legends
was mid season one I would say my cousin
introduced me to the game and I was
actually at his home and he played the
game and he was like you get this game i
just recently started playing it and I I
thought it was pretty nice and like it
was a game we could play together so I
just went home and downloaded the game
starts in trouble the challenge times
out one that gets the third killed the
fight in favor of life that could end up
just being the game here from first time
I had like okay maybe I should focus a
bit more listen and not like further my
education it was in CSUN for cs5 for
today because then I just finished my
elementary school and I had to go to
either high school or like take it was
kind of a gap year for me so I took that
while still playing a lot of league and
then that was kind of my first decision
to really commit into the game so what
the way is looking for a target to
challenge but it simply will not be
in a powerful not listed up Travis goes
down oldham of chachi Nisbet a wonder
where her on the back line running away
with their life my family has always
been a lot of like really supported so
they like my dad especially kind of like
wants to know everything so we check
like the news and on Danish gaming sites
and he tried to keep up to date
one-on-one was like a bit more passive
what's the supported my friends like a
lot of people know about like eSports or
they just thought it was was special but
also cool
the others
heading into the top plane has thought
Smith there's the actuation mark he
finds one the way gets locked down as
well of the boulder get cc'd four days
you are going anywhere wonder we're
looking for the extra hill he will get
it from the mantra if wonder where
doesn't survive the gangs which tends to
be the case it's difficult for him to
get back in the game and I might have
like a different perspective from the
criticism I like to even though I know I
performed badly I like to read it and
just laugh at it because offering it's
just a redditor or some Twitter analyst
writing this guy is really bad and he
did really bad in this situation and you
can just sit there and laugh at it
because no one really knows what's going
on behind the scenes everything you do
wind at the highest level of player
often has like some kind of lead up or
something like this so I just laugh at
it and obviously I know when I do that
and that this is what I I improve on
it's like everything I know i do bed and
my coach tells me and my team told me so
but we leave what a redditor would say
even though your mother looks old but
he's still there he's still pretty young
so he kind of has like the same the same
thoughts and routines as we do so we can
do a lot of stuff together but when it
screams and we have to be serious he's
he's the guy who takes charge as a team
we have always been pretty close I've
known same groups for a really long time
and he's like we have kind of grown up
in league together and we have been like
pretty childish both of us I know I know
like everything he does and things when
it's inside the game so like I know when
he tilts I know when it doesn't I think
we we get along pretty well and your
forward so looking forward dashes over
the wall but can't find a vital kick ass
is looking to use the hyper get excited
spurring young on the face and the
devastating charge against the wall it
won't kill go sanka stays alive wonder
goes forward report into lunge fanatical
right we all got a lot more usage so we
are like way more confident and I think
we just as a team developed so we scream
medical teams now and we can actually
get really well practice in scrims and
then of course we made our roster change
and that helped a bit in for some of the
players and the teams especially so we
just improved a lot and gotten a lot of
experience and then we have a rush to
change that helped a lot as well so
you